[Musique]
france 2022 l'heure du choix le choix
c'est dans moins de trois semaines
maintenant à choisir dire bonsoir
raphaël bonsoir à vous tous et j - 19
précisément avant le premier tour et
suite à des grands oraux ce mardi la
fédération nationale des chasseurs
tenait son assemblée donc générale à
paris en a profité pour auditionner
plusieurs candidats à la présidentielle
vu de l'étranger ça peut paraître
surprenant mais les chasseurs sont un
électorat très convoité ici en france un
million de personnes environ détient un
permis selon la fédération un réservoir
de voix qui pourrait faire la différence
pour accéder au second tour d'autant que
les chasseurs n'ont pas de candidat issu
de leurs rangs cette année contrairement
à 2002 par exemple ou encore 2007 le
récap politique est signée florent au
dos et nicolas houle
c'est l'histoire d'un marché qu'elle
connaît comme sa poche
24 ans après retour vers le futur pour
marine le pen dans son fief
d'hénin-beaumont des citations
'sur
encouragements selphy l'ambiance est bon
enfant
- quand il s'agit de parler d'eric
zemmour
nous semblait qu il avait abandonné ce
concept de re migration
qui sont étaient détachés éloigné je
vois qu'il leur prend je pense que ça
doit être lié à une situation électorale
qui est moins prometteuse que ce qui
laisse pas le bonheur du marché lui est
allé lui mais en région parisienne
partisan d'un ministère de la remise
gracieuse le candidat de reconquête veut
expulser beaucoup de monde de france les
délinquants et criminels étrangers les
clandestins aussi il n'ya plus de délit
de clandestinité depuis 2012 donc il
rétablira pour pouvoir les expulser on
peut imaginer au mois cent mille renvoi
par an voilà c'est la remise ration de
ces gens dont on ne veut plus en merde
petite tâche sur sa chemise rien à côté
de celle que représente emmanuel macron
pour l'extrême droite le président a
donné sa toute première interview de
candidats
pour moi les deux grands chantiers du
quinquennat à venir doivent être l'école
de la santé c'est mieux payé nos
enseignants il ya plusieurs milliards
qui seront dédiés à l'augmentation de la
rémunération de nos enseignants l'école
lui entend la réparer des dommages
causés par le chef de l'état yannick
jadot est catégorique macron à
maltraiter l'école je n'ai pas entendu
le président de la république remercier
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative
sur ce qu'ils avaient vécu ces dernières
années
comme jean luc mélenchon l'écologiste
n'est pas le bienvenu sur cette estrade
quatre candidats eux ont fait le
déplacement pour cette opération de
chasse aux voix de ceux qui la
pratiquent mode fermeté activé pour eric
zemmour et valérie pécresse mois
présidente jasters est la reconnaissance
du délit d' entrave encore une et
nombreuses promesses faites par le
candidat macro ya cinq ans jamais mise
en oeuvre ensuite par le président la
nature lui la connaît bien fils et petit
fils de paysan jean lassalle se sent
proche des chasseurs est un peu comme
moi des hommes parce qu'à mes mains
farouchement
charnellement
attachés à notre territoire
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
voilà et puis anne hidalgo et à limoges
meeting ce soir au parc des expositions
invité de marque l'ancien président
françois hollande venu lui apporter son
soutien plusieurs autres figures
socialistes sont d'ailleurs derrière
elle comme les anciens premiers
ministres bernard cazeneuve ou encore
jean marc ayrault mais ça ne suffit
visiblement pas la maire de paris créé
de deux et demi pour cent des intentions
de vote selon un dernier sondage ipsos
oprah steria publié aujourd'hui et c'est
l'heure à présent d'inaugurer une
nouvelle chronique dans ce france 2022
l'heure du choix la présidentielle pour
les nuls oui raphaël chaque semaine on
va tenter d'expliquer de manière
didactique les spécificités de
l'élection présidentielle en france qui
peuvent paraître complexes ou même
curieuse vu de l'étranger on va pour
cela retrouver florence vimines au grand
soir florence
pour ce premier décryptage ce soir on va
s'intéresser à la présidence elle même
une fois élu le nouveau président se
voit doté de nombreux pouvoirs lesquels
précisément selon les politologues le
président français et le chef de l'état
avec le plus de pouvoir alors en tout
cas par rapport à ses homologues dans
d'autres démocraties il a plus de
pouvoir par exemple que le premier
ministre britannique le chancelier
allemand et même le président des états
unis alors à l'échelle de la france on
est d'accord une fois élu le président
porte de nombreuses casquettes il ou
elle est tout d'abord chef de l'état ils
veillent donc au respect de la
constitution et garantit l'indépendance
nationale et l'intégrité du territoire
chef de l'état mais aussi chef de
l'exécutif vous l'avez dit plus de
pouvoir qu'un premier ministre tout à
fait c'est lui qui nomme le premier
ministre alors le premier ministre bien
sûr va défendre le programme du
gouvernement devant le parlement mais
c'est le président qui tient les
manettes et c'est le président qui
décide le calendrier des réformes le
président a d'ailleurs beaucoup de
pouvoir vis-à-vis du parlement il peut
dissoudre le parlement ou toutes ôtées
le contourner en ayant recours par
exemple un référendum
le président français est aussi le chef
des armées et c'est le seul à détenir le
feu nucléaire et enfin en cas de péril
nationale si des conditions très
spécifiques sont réunis le président
dispose de pouvoirs exceptionnels on
parle parfois des pouvoirs des pleins
pouvoirs et ça c'est grâce à l'article
16 de la constitution qui a été employé
une seule fois pour l'instant c'était
lors du putsch des généraux en algérie
c'était en 1961 beaucoup de pouvoir donc
pour le président la république d'où est
ce que ça vient alors on pourrait être
tenté de dire que c'est un héritage de
notre passé monarchique ici en france
mais en fait l'origine historique est
beaucoup plus récente je vais essayer
d'être assez synthétique parce que c'est
un peu compliqué mais un exécutif fort
est une caractéristique de la vème
république qui est entrée en vigueur
avec la constitution de 1958 la vème
république à qui succède à la ivème
république mis en place après la seconde
guerre mondiale la quatrième république
était une république parlementaire donc
le parlement avait beaucoup de pouvoir
mais c'est une république qui a été
marquée par une instabilité
gouvernementale chronique avec mme
arrière-plan la guerre d'algérie s'est
imposé alors la nécessité de donner à la
république une base plus solide et c'est
le général charles de gaulle qui s'en
est chargé c'est lui l'architecte de la
vème république on va l'écouter
d'ailleurs en 1958 face à ces critiques
auraient plu aux libertés publiques
fondamentales
il ya une seconde attendu jamais ou
quatre ans
une carrière
phrase restée célèbre du général de
gaulle d'ailleurs parmi ces critiques de
l'époque qu'ils n'ont pas ménager
certains ont fini par épouser ce système
présidentiel tout à fait c'est le cas de
françois mitterrand qui a qualifié dans
un livre la présidence mise en place par
le général charles de gaulle comme un
coup d'état permanent donc c'est ce
qu'il disait lorsqu'il était dans
l'opposition il l'a moins dix quand il
était président pendant 14 ans françois
hollande quant à lui avec l'ambition
d'être un président normal c'est ce
qu'il disait lorsqu'il était candidat en
2012 on va l'écouter dans le débat de
l'entre-deux tour face à nicolas sarkozy
écoutez françois hollande qu'elle
préside en compte et vous être un
président qui d'abord respecte les
français qui les considèrent
un président qui ne veut pas être
président de tout chef de tout et en
définitive responsable de rien je vais
évoquer présidence normale yann est
normal quand on est président de la
république puisque les conditions sont
exceptionnelles donc comme à chaque fois
qu'il ya une élection présidentielle en
france il ya des appels à réformer la
présidence c'est le cas de jean luc
mélenchon 1 notamment qui prône une
sixième république un régime
parlementaire qui réduire lé pouvoir du
président pour les transférer au
gouvernement
en attendant ce changement les critiques
que continue de qualifier le président
français comme un monarque républicain
ce qui est assez ironique pour un pays
qui s'est débarrassé ne sont pas merci
beaucoup florence et donc on vous
retrouvera désormais tous les mardis
pour ce nouveau module de décryptage et
sur la présidentielle en pleine
recrudescence du nombre de 99 plus de
180000 ces dernières 24 heures on
s'intéresse ce soir à l'électorat des
anti vaccins fresnes oui ils sont
environ 3 millions d'adultes français a
refusé de se faire vacciner un public
que le président macron elle s'est dite
décidée à emmerder en janvier dernier
des propos qui avaient suscité un tollé
plus de deux mois après la colère n'est
toujours pas retombée les antilles vax
compte bien exprimé leur indignation
dans l'isoloir les 10 et 24 avril
prochain mais pour qui comptent ils
voter reportage à paris de maya anaïs
iata guen
anti passe sanitaires ou anti vaccins
parfois les deux les voici partis à
l'assaut de l'elysée
au premier rang le souverainiste nicolas
dupont aignan il espère être le champion
de ce mouvement qui a mobilisé jusqu'à
200 milles personnes l'année dernière ce
que je voudrais maintenant qu'on a
compris que tout ça c'était du cinéma
que ce pass vaccinale est ce parce
sanitaire disparaissent qu'on ait eu nos
politiques sanitaires beaucoup plus
intelligente que les français ne se
trompent pas la suspension du pass
sanitaire n'est que provisoire et que si
monsieur macron est réélu eh bien ça
continuera nicolas dupont aignan peut
compter sur le soutien de florian
philippot l'ancien bras droit de marine
le pen n'hésite pas à tacler elle se
prononce contre le patrick sial depuis
quoi deux mois qu'on est en campagne
électorale elle a qualifié nos
manifestations je cite dans la presse un
de dinguerie voyez donc ça témoigne pas
d'une grande solidité d'une grande
fiabilité d'une grande sincérité dans
ses prises de position moi j'ai pas
confiance
le cortège est résolument hostile à
emmanuel macron
il n'a pas oublié les propos du chef de
l'état qui voulait emmerder les non
vaccinés et compte bien le faire savoir
dans les urnes ça je trouve que c'est
absolument indigne d'un président de la
république digne de ce nom et puis
ça parce qu'en fait les libertés qu'on
nous supprime son ne seront jamais
récupéré si on ne change pas
catégoriquement de régime six des sept
personnes qui peuvent sauver la france
donc je suis là pour ça et pour me
battre pour la liberté et pour
voilà pour la france en fait j'espère
qu'on va gagner j'espère compagnie voilà
ça
seul souhait pour le en france 3
millions d'adultes ne sont pas vaccinés
certains candidats ont été accusés de
vouloir récupérer cet électorat
potentiel nous étions donc contre se
passe sanitaire nous voici contre le
pass vaccinale parce qu'il est 100%
inefficace est le droit à la liberté ne
se négocie pas même si parfois il nous
contrarie plusieurs études affirment que
les anti-pacs sanitaires et anti vaccins
auryn tendance à l'abstentionnisme comme
les gilet jaune avant eux leur forte
mobilisation ne s'est jamais retrouvé
dans les urnes
on en veut à présent nos images
d'archivés du jour oui elles font écho
au grand oral du jour devant les
chasseurs un électorat on l'a dit
traditionnellement très convoités par
les candidats à la présidentielle mais
certains présidents de la vème
république étaient eux-mêmes des
chasseurs ou ont fait vivre la tradition
des chasses présidentielles qui
apparaissent sous la deuxième république
en 1848 vous voyez ici charles de gaulle
à rambouillet sous georges pompidou
maintenant les chasses présidentielles
deviennent plus régulière ici vous le
voyez au sein du domaine de chambord
dans le loir-et-cher s'est battu
rassembler des hommes politiques des
diplomates ou encore des militaires
quant à valéry giscard d'estaing ici
donc à l'image il aimait beaucoup la
chasse parfois même de nuit ici donc en
1976 à chambord voilà c'est tout pour ce
centre raphaël merci h rennes france
2022 lors du show on se retrouve demain
bien sûr à la même heure et nous dans 5
minutes pour un nouveau journal rester
avec nous à part égale
[Musique]